420 means a lot of things to
different people but broadly speaking
is the unofficial holiday for
cannabis it's also the biggest sales
event of the year the most widely
accepted origin story of 420
has its start in 1971 at san rafael high
school in
maryland county california
we've been friends for over 50 years and
we used to sit on a wall at centerfield
high school
in the middle of the campus and we'd
watch people going by and
do impressions of them and make jokes
and try to make each other's laugh and
that's how
we became the waldos from sitting on the
wall one day
a friend of a friend brought them a
hand-drawn map and said hey my brother
is a coast guard and he planted
some some weed plants and he said these
guys were going marijuana
for some reason they thought that their
commanding officer was going to bust
them and they didn't want to get busted
so they decided to
abandon this growing project they said
we could pick it they said that the
coast guardsmen grew a map of where it
was and he had the map he showed me the
map
and we decided hey let's go pick it
we all looked at it and he told us what
the story was
and all of us were going to get together
meet at 4
20 and search for these hidden plants
they set the time at 4 20 p.m they would
meet at this statue
and uh on campus light a joint jump in
the car and
go you know on an adventure trying to
look for these plants
so it went on for several weeks and they
never found him
but they did coin the term 420.
we could say 420 is our secret code in
front of our parents
cops teachers everybody and nobody knew
what it was and it was our
little private joke and it spread to the
wider circle of friends that we had it
spread to our younger brothers
it sped spread to their classmates so it
started going from class to class to
class it started going through
generation
you go to college and your college
buddies they pick up and they're from
all over the united states
my brother patrick was had was good
friends with
phil lesch the basis from the grateful
dead for 50 years
now phil asked my brother pat if he'd
like to manage
a couple of side bands while they're
dead we're taking some time off
so i worked with them uh touring around
california
doing shows and uh i was backstage
smoking with
with phil lash and guys like david
crosby
and uh terry hagerty and a host of other
musicians and we
patrick my brother and i were spreading
420 backstage and then it kind of
filtered through the uh you know the
roadies and the people who are hanging
out and that spread throughout the dead
community
and after that the entire world you know
with the proliferation of
state legalization i feel like we forget
that like in the 90s marijuana was
was not okay really the term 420
is a vestige of the past like of drug
suppression
of you know anti-drug psas
perhaps the biggest irony of that this
whole
cultural phenomenon is that what started
as a joke between
a couple of stones teenagers has
blossomed into
the biggest sales event of the industry
this year the legal cannabis industry
you know which is across 17 states for
adult use
and over 30 states for medical is going
to bring in
20 billion dollars in sales
what's special this year is that it's
the 50th anniversary
of the waldos coining the term 420.
there's only three states that have not
amended their marijuana laws so when you
think about it on that level
the tipping point is here the latest
gallup poll
put it at 68 of americans want
marijuana to be legal or at least feel
that it should be
legal in the 70s you know that same stat
was like you know around 15
it's been 50 years of uh the creation of
420 but it's been over 50 years of our
friendship and that's the most
important thing that we have going here
is that we're still all alive and
pretty much healthy and we're still
friends we want to celebrate our
friendship
and the spirit of 420 of
friendship humor and kindness
you